o salve no non indisturbate affatto
stavamo facendo finta di leggere un
libro per fare finta di essere conto
alla fine non è così che funziona
internet mi sono sempre considerato un
uomo normale con una vita anonima la
celebrità di te non ha mai inciso nella
mia vita ed è per questo che quando
un'occasione di ringraziarvi per
qualcosa lo faccio sempre sarà ospite
del comicon di napoli 2014 sarà lì il 3
e il 4 maggio ma se volete altre
informazioni vi consiglio di andare
dell'informazione di questo video e
adesso giro perché fatica come
transizione lo so che gli state già
preparando alla tua bambina un cazzo c'è
il mio compia comicon di napoli non nel
bene cosa vi posso dire per me è
un'occasione grandiosa per incontrare
ognuno di voi è vero giuro non canterò
mai più come nell'ultimo video mai più
quindi che altro dire 3 4 maggio comicon
di napoli e ci andiamo a mangiare tutti
la bella pizza e stereotipo sedico pizza
per napoli no vabbè io la voglio e non
so che siete tutti super eccitati
all'idea infatti i primi commenti sono
stati non vedo l'ora che venga così lo
prendono a sprangate sui denti lo vedo
l'ora di arrivare e come ultima cosa
volevo dire
grazie grazie perché l'unione di due
cose molto importanti come il vostro
gusto del nord e la mia non voglia di
studiare ci hanno portato qui e io se
fossi bisessuale vi bacerei tutti
imbecille